in this last lecture of this unit we
continue with some of our earlier themes
and then introduce one new notion the
notion of independence of random
variables we will start by elaborating a
bit more on the subject of conditional
probability mass functions we have
already discussed the case where we
condition a random variable on an event
here we will talk about conditioning a
random variable on another random
variable and we will develop yet another
version of the total probability and
total expectation theorem there are no
new concepts here just new notation I
should say however that notation is
important because it guides you on how
to think about problems in the most
economical way the one new concept that
we will introduce is the notion of
independence of random variables it is
actually not an entirely new concept it
is defined more or less the same way as
independence of events and has a similar
intuitive interpretation two random
variables are independent if information
about the value of one of them does not
change your model or beliefs about the
other on the mathematical side we will
see that independence leads to some
additional nice properties of means and
variances we will conclude this lecture
and this unit on discrete random
variables by considering a rather
difficult problem the hard problem we
will see that by being systematic and
using some of the tricks that we have
learned we can calculate the mean and
variance of a rather complicated random
variable